you have produced all three of these
films and were you were the one who
brought you and your partner brought
them too broad a script to Garry
Marshall of of Valentine's Day yes when
no one was that well what happened is a
writer named Katherine Katherine Foo J
had just seen love actually and we work
we were working with her on another
project and she came to us and said what
do you think about doing Valentine's Day
like Love Actually and we thought it's a
great idea different stories emotions
and so we started developing with
Catherine and after we had the script
then we brought it to Gary and that
would have been early 2000s now does he
have it in the case with this one too
does he always have the writers on the
set with him if he comes up with
something or also does he talk to the
actors if they have ideas too how does
that work it's a great question so he
he's always writing he's always writing
and he has two sometimes three writers
with him right behind him at the
monitors constantly pitching him ideas
he's got it's fascinating and one writer
Martine a blur it's been with him since
I think the odd couple in the 70s and is
retired in Martha's Vineyard and comes
out of retirement for every Gary movie
and he just sits behind Gary and he just
pitches him jokes and if Gary likes it
he puts in his pocket if he doesn't he
throws it right back on Marty some
Marty's doing jokes and then Gary has a
few other writers who were writing more
of the scenes and structural stuff but
he's always writing and I remember on
Valentine's Day it was it was a maybe
the first week of filming and I'm on set
and Gary comes driving up in his car he
gets down he hands me some pages he says
I just thought of this last night I'd
like to do them and we were like okay so
we were scrambled but there's new roles
and new characters that weren't cast
that are working in five hours I suggest
new dialogue it as a joke right and
we're like okay let's do it i said but
who's going to do it he goes oh I
already have the guys they're coming and
then we and then the next day new pages
and then we realized he's always
rewriting he's always adding stuff and
throwing out little jokes and little
scenes and it works no the decision on
Mother's Day did you once the
Valentine's Day was such a big hit with
Lee an idea to do
trilogy then or was it after you know
let's do one with student you know New
Year's Eve and if that does well let's
go for go for a trilogy how did that
work out well you know how it works as
everybody in the room knows you start
working on a movie in the first week you
think of this is pretty good and then
the third or fourth week are thinking
this is really good and by the end of
the movie you think we've made gone with
the wind it's just that you put your
heart and soul into a moving your you
just give up so much and you just feel
you've made a great movie so by the end
of Valentine's Day we were pretty we
were feeling pretty good about it and
and we started talking on the set with
the studio execs a new line you know if
this does well what the next movie be
and and and we kind of came to the
conclusion that should be New Year's Eve
because that's a movie that's universal
as universal themes and also would play
well over the throughout the world so
the minute the movie open and did well
new line put that script that idea into
development and then on the set of New
Year's Eve we're thinking it would be
the next one if this does well and we
man we were kind of thinking mother's
day would be the next one and how does
that work then because I know some of
the writers are actually in the movie
the one guy is the is the clown is one
of the writers was it almost immediately
that Gary and you and writers sat down
because I guess he's worked with those
guys a lot sat down and decided to throw
out ideas well actually there was a
script we've gotten from a random Lily
Hollander that Gary had optioned and
then he hired matt walker and Tommy
Hinds who were kind of his writing
partners now to come with more ideas and
then Matt timing Gary reddit another
script for Mother's Day which was great
and then we brought in some more writers
and then a woman named Anya Koch F
Romano finished it and did a great job
and then man Tommy on the set were
rewriting as well so it was a long
four-year process was there any it was a
personal lost some of these stories when
the writers were thinking up ideas did
they also go to unit room their
experiences
mother's day or with their mothers oh
I'm sure I'm sure and and the way we do
it is we we picked the holiday then we
come up with as many storylines as we
can so there were four central story
lines in this movie but we probably had
10 to 15 that we had talked about before
settling on these central ones because
you only have you don't have foreign
that I think you said you had more in
Valentine's Day what was the decision to
not only to just do four but also it's
the week leading up and then at the end
everybody meets up on Valentine on
Mother's Day what was the decision to
kind of change the format a bit and
that's a that's a good question we we
thought we didn't want to do the same
thing we just thought the audience we're
going to expect a little something a
little different so we were thinking
that let's focus on fewer storylines and
let the audience really kind of get
their teeth into a smaller amount of
storylines and then it would also allows
maybe to get bigger stars because they
had more media trend to work with so
that was one idea and then in terms of
not having the movie set on one day
again we just want to do something a
little different so we said instead of
setting on one day let's set it on the
week before mother's day to give us time
to play out stories in a different way
and you know the first two movies were
new line and this is open road so you
kind of went in more of an indie route
in this what was the decision behind
that well the business has changed
pretty dramatically now a lot of the
focuses on the tent pole you know movies
and this is not one of those obvious
tent pole so the best way to get this
movie done was to do the in ear at which
was to pre-sell foreign find a state
that had a good rebate and kind of back
into it and I thought olanta worked
really well for this I mean cuz you know
there were neighborhoods the city looks
very cosmopolitan but different than New
York and LA did you find did the actors
and everybody find working there
enjoyable oh yeah and I think every
actor in the movie had already been
there too right nytimes the last few
years working on movies but we um we we
hadn't really set the movie in the
script anywhere it was just a kind of
9010 USA and we got there and after the
first week we still
thinking why don't we just have it be
Atlanta it's a it's a great city and it
looks different and it's in the south we
had LA we had in New York we thought the
third one should be in a different city
anyway so it was really the first or
second week we just committed to Atlanta
Georgia and just set the movie there and
we think it works creatively also I mean
going from beaches to you know pretty
woman runaway bride and now you know
with this he's he's known for
female-centric characters and you know
strong characters was that also one of
the reasons to you could get such a
terrific cast of I mean Jennifer
Aniston's new to the repertory company
but you know Kate did raising Helen and
then she was also a little girl on the
set of overboard and of course Julia you
know this is the fourth film they've
done together do you find that when you
say Gary Marshall that a lot of
actresses naturally want to be involved
because of how he works with women and
that he doesn't shy away from portraying
women on screen I think so and I think
he takes a lot of pride in the way he
could tell stories for and with women
and I think it's a big draw for some of
the female actresses he have he hasn't
worked with and I think jen has said
that it was a bucket list for her she
just wanted to work with Carrie and she
just jumped at the chance of doing it
also um it's interesting because Julia
played a soldier in Valentine's Day and
what common was in New Year's Eve and
then we see Jennifer Garner and as you
know Jason Sudeikis wife who had died
the decision to have a character a vet
in each of these films well the military
is dear to Gary he was in the armed
services um during the Korean War and I
think it really influenced him and i
think i think it's it's you see it in
his movies it's important he feels it's
important to portray the military in the
film's umm I have to ask you about the
wig that does this session with Julia
remember it i guess in pretty woman she
had a white wig but it was sort of that
and i read somewhere that that wig was
also used in not
he'll in a scene with what was the
decision it's this is the gentleman I
produce a movie with Wayne rice and we'd
last two this is the question we've got
asked a lot in the last couple weeks but
he uh but she was Julia's idea she
called Gary up a few days before she was
heading to Georgian sand I got an idea I
like to wear the wig that I wore in
Notting Hill then the movie she was
promoting right here I finally the
sci-fi movie and Gary looked at the
pictures online and said that sounds
good and so I'm julia's rationale was
the character in the movie she's kind of
hiding behind you know a facade and and
it's this kind of it's just character
she's created this saleswoman and and
she just thought I work creatively
forward and Gary blasted and she showed
up with the actual wig from Notting Hill
and a couple people picked up on her
pretty quickly in the early screenings
and then Julia told some of the press it
was the actual wig there's also a Hector
was on the morning news yesterday and he
was talking about it was the scene where
he's talking about his his upbringing
and it's you know the train scene that
you know and there's something about the
fork that it or the spoon and that was
like the homage to a pretty woman and
that he actually started break kind of
crying at that scene well um yeah in in
in Valentine's Day there was a scene
where Julia's in the limo heading to see
her kid at the end the movie and the
driver says he Herman every herb into
Beverly Hills and she goes once a big
mistake and we put it in the gag reel
and it was the biggest laugh in the
whole movie because it was referencing
pretty women so I think Gary and Hector
and Julie we're looking to do it again
with this one and so enhance the salad
fork line thank you for coming thank you
i hope everybody liked the movie